please give a warm welcome to the
producers of missing Natalie Kasabian
sevohanian and anishaganti
congratulations
[Applause]
next up the writing and directing Duo
behind the film please say hello to will
Merrick and Nick Johnson
thank you
and finally the star of missing we have
storm read here tonight
[Applause]
my God this movie is a feat I don't know
how you all pull this off but we're
gonna try to at least get some of the
details right now I'm going to go to my
producing Trio first to to get us
started
was there ever a point a niche where you
considered directing the searching
follow-up yourself and ultimately what
was it about these two right here that
made you all feel like yes we can hand
the reins over to also these two here
edited searching so they know what
they're doing but what did you see in
their work on that film that gave you
the confidence that they could do it I
mean I've known these guys since I was
in college they've uh will Merrick
edited some of my earliest work that
started my career and we've been working
together since then they edited
searching they edited run and when
you've when you've seen searching you
can't you don't you don't just edit this
movie you are one of the core filmmakers
of this movie
um and they learned everything it was no
question after you make a movie like
this you'd never want to touch computer
screens again which for me I was like
never doing that again these guys know
everything and more so we went to them
easily
Pepper for you two now so you have
collaborated before I'm sure on previous
projects you've developed some sort of
shorthand but when you jump into a film
like this where you're also the writers
and directors I imagine that shorthand
has to evolve so what is the biggest
difference in that respect and I don't
know it's really hard to describe the
difference in what we do Natalie you
said in one of those interviews it's
like a left brain right brain thing
where like we both do everything but in
a different way I don't know
yeah I think um with will and I it was a
very natural progression of working
together
um I think one of the cool things about
our our team the five of us is that it's
been such a collaborative team from
searching through run and this that it
just felt like a natural like we all
have different roles but we're all still
there still the same five people making
making a movie you know so a really
special thing to have such a large group
of people who are who are key
collaborators in a production like that
I keep that like you three you two then
you won well here I get to you in a
second but when you're when you're
working like a team of five here can any
of you speak to like how you collaborate
efficiently and also make sure you're
all on the same page but also giving the
production your own personal Insight
that makes you a particularly good team
together the real answer Google Docs and
text chains the thing that I think makes
this team work and I'd like to think it
does work and you guys may be the judge
of that having watched the movie is that
everyone is fighting for the same thing
and that's the movie at all times you
know ego aside what's the best thing for
this movie and yes sometimes it turns
into like very passionate debates and
arguments but at the end of the day as
long as we're making the right movie
that tells emotion and the Cinematic
Journey we want to take the audience on
we know that's the right answer that's
why I keep coming back for more of your
movies all right storm you're up so a
movie like this obviously has to be shot
in a very unique way when you first sign
on for the role what are some of your
biggest burning questions for these five
right here in terms of what it takes to
make a screen Thriller like this yeah I
mean
um I read the missing script and I was
totally engaged I was at the edge of my
seat the entire time when I thought I
knew what was going on I figured out I
had nothing
um and I knew nothing that was happening
but I think I don't think I asked the
question but repeatedly while we were in
pre-production I was just like how are
we gonna do this like how are we gonna
pull this off but I was so comfortable
on set they made me feel so comfortable
and and so
um it was a easy easy process and yes it
was challenging because you know I had
to hold the camera and hold the
computers and it wasn't like a film that
I have ever filmed before but I think
once I got the hang of it and we got a
flow and and Will and Nick um we of
course created a bond and we worked
really well together I think it turned
out well just tell her really quickly
how good is this movie and how good
you'll have to tell me
thank you thank you like five times
earlier today I'm gonna keep making it
happen happen tonight thank you
given given the challenge of making a
movie like this going into it what
particular part of the process did you
think was going to be the toughest thing
for you and then ultimately was that
indeed the toughest or did something
else Catch You by surprise absolutely I
knew going in because I had watch
searching uh when the opportunity came
about and I knew that it was going to be
really good but the technical aspect was
going to be challenging and and
everything is shot through a computer
shot through a ring camera like it's not
traditional so I knew that it was going
to be a challenge and it was a challenge
but like I said once we figured it out
once we got the hang of it once I
figured out how to hold the computer
correctly and the eye lines eyelines was
a big thing once I figured out the eye
lines I think it was seamless eyelines
are hard enough on a more traditional
film I I was thinking about it the
entire time I'm watching this I can't
even imagine how you pulled it all off
get getting into the the production
process here I'm going to go back to my
producing Trio down there for for all of
you what is something that worked really
well on searching that you knew you had
to replicate in missing but then also
what's a part of that production process
that you thought could be improved and
need some refining and you had the
opportunity to do it here
yeah one thing we did on searching was
before we actually got to set and before
we started even prepping the film we did
a whole previous of the movie so we had
like a rough assembly using uh on
searching it was a niche on this one it
was Will and Nick acting out like all
the roles and basically that gave us
like a road map so when we got to set we
had this thing that we were able to pull
up as a reference for the actors if they
needed it or for the department heads to
basically say like this is what your
portion that we're filming today the
live action this is how it's going to
fit into the full frame so I think that
was really helpful
not so helpful I don't know what could
we do better you guys have anything
we're perfect I feel like we I feel like
we approached Easter eggs totally
differently you know like with the first
film one of the things we were so
excited about was how much excitement
there was about all the little words in
the back of the like on you know Google
Chrome or when you type in a search bar
all the little drop downs and from the
beginning we were like okay Easter eggs
is a huge element of this movie let's
start and we Sev wrote a whole storyline
on his own uh that is fully in the film
like a kind of a maybe a sequel to the
alien storyline that was in the first or
isn't searching and these guys did a
massive amount yeah
so do you want to talk about the aliens
yeah I mean okay remind me guys who here
in searching
okay did you guys know what the
background so searching is about a
father searching for his missing
daughter
in the background of that movie on the
sides of the screen with the comments
and the news articles and the tweets
there's events happening and that event
is an alien invasion did anyone know
this I'm curious hey hey
so if you guys ever get a chance to
rewatch this movie which you will on
January 20th in theaters everywhere
watch closely because you might find out
what happened with those aliens I'll
just say that
I like that cheese I like the teas will
Nick I have to go back to you because I
want to follow up on the previous thing
who like who played who when you were
acting it out for the previous what
scene was the most fun I sincerely hope
that never sees the light of day
if we were cooped up in our houses at
the peak of the pandemic it's just cabin
fever and acting out every every role
will went up on his roof yeah
went up on the roof totally unnecessary
by the way totally unnecessary you're
right I didn't need to do that I have a
serious question about doing that
because it's not often that the
directors the writer and directors get
the opportunity to act out their own
scripts yeah is there anything is there
anything about the script that you
discovered that you change because of
having done that absolutely I think the
previous was in some ways the final
rewrite of the script we were assembling
the movie watching the movie back and
realizing oh that line or or or that you
know that uh scene isn't actually
working the way we thought it was so it
was a perfect way to refine the story
and the script before we actually send
it out and embarrassed ourselves uh in
front of actors
how about when it comes to your editing
process so I know you two developed a
way to do all of this when you worked on
searching but here you passed those
reins over to Arielle and Austin and I
had read somewhere that they kind of
added and evolved that system so where
did you guys start and how did they
change it yeah I they took over and made
the the finishing process was about the
same but the editing process got quite a
bit faster because of some changes they
made that are probably too technical to
be worth going into but we basically we
used to have to count frames in an edit
we would say I'm going to shorten the
shot by four frames and then we would go
into a whole other sequence and change
that by four frames and they managed to
solve that problem so we didn't need to
do that anymore which really helped some
very as well
how long was this script and then how
long did the script wind up being if you
add in all of the stuff that we see on
screen in addition to the main action
I think um the the script itself was
longer than its run time do you guys
remember it was like 129 Pages or
something yeah it was enough to be like
this movie's you know it might be a
little long but um when we assembled it
it played a lot faster if we were to
include all the copy and everything that
we wrote in the background it'd be like
a 500 page epic
encyclopedia little thing yeah and then
ultimately how much footage do you
because you're you're recording multiple
cameras a whole bunch of different ways
how much footage are you in that edit
room with probably Le probably about on
par or less than a normal movie would
have the footage was not that
overwhelming the graphics on the other
hand insane
I can imagine because we get all of
those details and that's why we have um
alien invasion subplots in a movie like
this
storm for you picking up that script for
the very first time what was it like
reading that are you fully able to
picture what this movie could be or were
you given any kind of supplemental
material to help really paint a clear
picture for you no I think the the
script did an amazing job of painting
the picture that
um they wanted to create and and I
clearly saw their Vision when I was
reading it and not only like I said
before I was on the edge of my seat and
I was just like so excited to be reading
it and all the twists and turns were
really intriguing but I try to be as
intentional as possible when choosing
projects and I felt that even though
this was a thriller and yes uh
um a movie that is made for the big
screen it has intention it has purpose
and I think missing at its core is a
movie about family about love about
unconditional love about making
sacrifices about growing about
self-discovery there are so many things
and so many themes that I think were
touched on whether they were in a
preachy way or not I don't think the
movie's preachy at all um but like
whether the the messages that I I
resonated with were pretty preachy or
not I felt like it had a purpose it's
not just a a film that is entertaining
it's entertaining and purposeful I think
I think it does and it captures some of
what you were we were talking about this
earlier I love I love the idea of a
movie being a slice of someone's life
but still being able to feel like they
lived a full life and have a past that's
informing their present during something
like this and you very much accomplish
that speaking of that just for you
personally you're working with a great
script here but what kind of backstory
details or like you know like the space
between the lines on the page do you
have to fill in for yourself that we
don't necessarily see or hear about in
the film but we can feel informing your
performance and making June whole yeah I
mean I think it it for me with any
character that I I embody I think it is
trying to step into my character shoes
and become them and and really feel how
they would feel in their given
circumstance but you know I'm also a
young human that has emotions that has
feelings um and I try not to neglect
those feelings while I'm acting because
I think my emotions and my feelings and
my thoughts are beneficial and and can
inform my character so I think it's more
so of a intersection of like yes I am
June but storm would feel a type of way
in this situation too so how do you
marry those two for it to be a good
marriage and it could be grounded and it
could be as beautiful as possible so it
was a little challenging because you
know again it's those technical aspects
of like oh yeah the stakes are high-end
my emotions are high-end but you still
gotta look up because there's a
notification that's a little challenging
that's a little challenging but I I
think with uh with this role it wasn't
it wasn't hard to embody June at all the
three of you could probably speak to
this together but but what is the
director actor collaboration like how
are you giving notes what is it like
receiving those notes but focusing on
the emotional beats the performance how
does all that work these guys are so fun
to work with like the the biggest balls
of energy
um I think it was fun I mean I didn't
have any problem working with them are
you kidding me I mean good directing to
me is good casting and when you cast an
actress like storm it makes our jobs
much easier
um like you don't you don't have to
communicate as much it's just little
tweaks sometimes it comes down to just
technical things like that was amazing
but uh just remember to look up there
yeah next time yeah what are you seeing
when you could see like uh like
close to finish previous versus maybe
any other kind of thing that they could
substitute for the visual references on
set
once we had the previous done we did
consult it but we didn't really need to
look at it that much we mainly just
needed to know like what side of the
screen is she on
um so so there wasn't really too much of
that from a technical perspective really
a lot of our job was just to see the
movie in our head and then just make
sure that you were able to bring storm
like the the authenticity of it and just
make sure that whatever you were doing
was going to fit into that picture and
storm when you're looking at a device
what are you seeing Oh I would see a lot
of nothing
um I the computer that we used to shoot
most of the scenes it was like a blank
screen with like boxes at Each corner or
like folders at each yeah like folders
that on like in each corner so I would
know where to look
um or I mean sometimes I'd get fortunate
and it would be a real FaceTime call and
that was really cool but most of the
time it was just really working with
these guys and in the team to let me
know if I was doing it right what I
needed to do do more in a technical
aspect because I didn't really get to
share scenes with a lot of people
is there is there any freedom like if
storm feels the urge to to do something
in a different way on set for you to
change in in post-production where
things are positioned on a screen
yeah yeah certainly there was there was
freedom and occasionally just by chance
if she happened to look over here we'd
be like oh that's perfect let's use that
a little bit
um so yeah I think making a movie like
this gives you a lot of latitude and
post to to change it up a little bit but
for the most part going into it we knew
exactly where she was clicking by that
point so it was really a matter of
checking that list and being like we got
it move on usually in those instances
it's not like my character would look
over here it's like why is my character
even at a computer right now
like why is she right here I did I did
have a question about a specific visual
technique you guys use the the punching
shots how do you do something like that
to up the tension but without ever feel
like without it ever feeling like you're
TR you're cheating the screen life
concept where that like because that's
not how it would look to someone looking
at a screen like taking them out of that
feeling because I think you do that
really well here you use it very
effectively without ruining the illusion
right I mean I would argue that when you
look at a screen it what that feels like
to you is a punch in you're not ever
taking in the totality of your whole
screen you know all we're doing is
upresing it a little bit I feel like
this is how my brain has morphed over
the years where I am glued to a screen
that I don't realize that's happening
but that that is definitely how I
operate now
I want to back up a little bit and go
back to the very beginnings of the story
and I'll give this one Anish and Sev
because you guys have Story by credits
here what was idea number one was it
strictly we need to make another
searching was it the kidnap plot was it
a specific character what was the thing
that started it all
uh the truth is when we release
searching a couple years back we also we
would often get asked will you guys ever
make a sequel and we we always knew for
sure no no we will never make a sequel
so
um the the honest to God answer is I I
got a call from Sony a couple months
after the movie came out and they were
like you guys ready let's do searching
two John Cho goes after someone else
who's missing and we were like maybe but
um I I we were I was hesitant I think
you know for us it's like we really were
proud of that film and the whole team
here had done such a great job on that I
remember I hung up the phone I happened
to be working right next to a good
friend of mine who's a director himself
a guy named Ryan coogler I'll direct the
Black Panther
and this is this is a 100 true story I
remember I hung up the phone and he kind
of saw me laughing and he was like what
was that I was like dude Sony wants to
make a sequel to searching and his
reaction was like dude hell yeah and I
was like I don't know man I gotta talk
tonight I gotta talk to Anish and I was
like maybe we don't do this and he I
remember he looked at me like ride my
eyes and he was like if anyone can make
a sequel to that film it's you guys so
he was like you all have to do it I
called these guys they had the same
initial reaction as me then we were like
who's gonna direct it and then we
realized we have the greatest directors
right there and then and then we started
ideating on like what could the sequel
be yeah we went through a lot of ideas
but we went back to the first one you
know like Sev came
and we pitched this early version of of
missing which was essentially a reversal
of searching but like we explored a
thousand different ideas like serial
killer like just all these random uh
approaches and realize like wow just
simply switching the protagonist keeps
what's the heart of this movie but it
allows a totally different perspective
of the internet you know like by just
making the character a teenager we've
now changed the tone and the style of
the film like these guys have brought
such we call it we in in the editing
room early on there was basically like
if searching was a Sam raimi's
Spider-Man what we're trying to do or
what these guys are trying to do is do
into the spider-verse you know like make
it fresher funner more active more
thrilling so yeah
that was a good idea and then we landed
back on that and then we just kept
developing it and developing it and
developing it and a few months later we
turned it into the studio and these guys
got started writing but the real story
is we just wanted a free vacation to
Colombia yeah so we just wrote the part
of Hannah part I mean it was a really
lovely time great lesson next time
anytime we write something it'll start
exterior like London and then we'll
we'll go there I love that spider-verse
comp I'm not gonna forget that
um jumping way ahead with the writing
process Will and Nick so that's where it
all started do you remember the last
story idea you came up with that really
felt like it brought everything together
so when Anish and I were writing the
story we wrote ourselves into a into a
corner and then she has this big
realization this big Eureka moment that
was those guys and I remember when they
pitched that to us we were like it's so
good it was like Wow Let's Make a whole
movie around that exactly
getting into some specifics here
non-spoiler one storm I'll go to you
first I'm obsessed with detailed
production design and I love looking
around the frames at what's on the
computer screens but I was also busy
looking at the background of June's room
is there anything that's back there that
you think really informs who she is that
you hope people take notice of oh wow I
think so I mean I think June is just so
cool as a character
um and I think she's just really cool
um and her room was really cool and like
just like the different like gidgets and
gadgets and like the colors and I think
her room really informed her personality
and then you know even the t-shirt that
she wears like it's it's everything is
intentional everything is sentimental
everything is like down to the small
details I felt it on set and I
appreciated all the details that the
that the team put in you know there was
a passive War over what color purple to
make the walls of your room oh yeah
battling about it oh no I'm curious why
why was the color so important like
character or visually uh a little bit of
both we were just like do we want to
flood everything out on a room with too
dark of a purple we landed on a good one
but I I think I think it it goes hand in
hand with the fact that we wanted this
to feel more youthful
um and so we wanted to inject some color
into into it and give it it's um you
know like my room I live in like cult I
have all this these flux bulbs in my
room you know that's how I live so we
wanted to make something that felt real
to how like teenagers live these thanks
for bringing that one back around
you will ask you guys all at the end of
this to on a poll how the purple was so
I've already talked about
drag here we don't want to spoil
anything but is there anything else that
you hid in this movie that you are
especially proud of that you hope that
people find when they watch this movie
over and over and over oh yeah but
you'll never find it
can you give it I mean I can't tell
where to look I love there's one that I
think the credit goes to stuff for this
one but in in searching David Kim Don
Cho's character if you guys are paying
attention like on the sidelines he's
been dating this woman named Hannah
couch
and at the beginning of the movie he's
kind of answering her but by the end
he's obviously looking for his daughter
so his priorities have shifted and he's
like kind of ghosting her uh Hannah
couch may or may not be going after
someone in this film as well
pay attention to the dating Montage
there are a lot of really great
searching uh searching references as
well one of my favorites that will added
I think it was you was the app insurer
um David David Kim's company app insure
there's a little newsletter in there and
at some point uh a character in
searching asks if the Integrations
report on the Bellington system is
complete and uh the email uh in fact
confirms that the integration that the
billing system is fully integrated yeah
we worked on the we edit these movies
and work on them for so long we have to
find ways to entertain pure Cabin Fever
ultimately it adds to the experience and
entertains us all too so that's good
here's the most important question I
could possibly ask who does Quinn the
cat belong to
my watch just judged my question I feel
like spider versus happening to me right
now who is the owner of Quinn the cat
that's Arielle zakowski our editor's cat
or her sister's cat on the phone it's
her sister's cat I think it's her
sister's cat and then the cat that
appears in the movie was actually a
variety of cats selected based on their
mood at the moment those cats were candy
these cats just make me happy another
thing that I always find interesting to
talk about is selecting the title for
your movie because you could have gone
searching too you could have used a word
that has the same meaning as missing but
something different why why this
particular title for this film
uh Glass Onion and knives out mystery
was taken yeah so we just you know have
you did you guys go for it now we we
spent yeah we spend a ton of time on
this and one of the things we debated
was like how do we bring in the audience
at scene searching but we also don't
want to alienate people that may have
not seen the first film because this
does stand on its own so there was a lot
of debates of like do we do something
and then a searching story to subs or
like Cloverfield which would do like 10
Cloverfield Lane you know like could we
use the word searching in a sentence
like integrated searching abroad was the
early idea that we threw out because the
tone of that those two words wasn't
right but like something like that where
it sounds like its own title but it's
actually searching another title but
ultimately we ended up with missing well
we we threw out a lot of ideas and at
one point we were all campaigning for
different our own ideas it was war and
we were like yeah actually hold on hold
on we have a real audience here take a
poll these mofos literally
I I had the great that I love missing as
a title don't get me wrong but I had the
greatest title on the planet
number one number two these people had
no faith can you guys for once and for
all settle three years of our tax
debates okay
if this title of this film was just I'ma
spell it
s
r
C
h
search raise your hand if you like that
at all
crickets
we got we got a fan over there missing
it is
we like had so many conversations that
would end with like okay in one hour
we're ending with the title guys like
we're not leaving this meeting without a
title we had that meeting week after
week after week after week after week
and eventually we're just like what do
we do and when the title missing came up
it was just like that makes total sense
it came from Sony yeah it was great yeah
yeah someone pitched it I think in our
team I don't think we even remember
because we were like and we were like
yeah we were like maybe and then as time
went on it just kept like making it into
this meeting that Anisha is alluding to
and it just never got eliminated so we
were like that's the time I became
useless pretty quickly because I could
only think of titles that rhymed with
searching too and my brain was just
broken
I mean this in all seriousness do you
have a thing with one word film titles I
I find them to be very effective and
like powerful to just say one word but
like we have searching run and now
missing and our next one a few more yeah
a few more single word titles yeah I
guess we love them it's like now it's a
thing I I there's I mean one word I
think we're coming from like I feel like
with all of our styles of writing it's
just like eliminating all the fat I feel
like a lot of the time and what we write
and it's so like purposeful and I feel
like you can do that with one word you
know and we definitely all agree find
that one word is such like an easy quick
way to raise Intrigue too and I feel
like these three words in particular are
very effective with that before I toss
it over to the audience for for the five
of you at this point two films in with
this type of Storytelling format do you
have a screen Thriller like white whale
of sorts something that you really want
to be able to do with this storytelling
format that you haven't been able to
because I don't know the technology
doesn't exist or you haven't quite
cracked it that you hope to do on a
future film
no like general idea of like a story but
all the time like things happen I think
just in our daily lives and we'll
literally write it down be like if we do
a third one like this has to go in
um so I think we we go through our lives
now thinking about good screen beats
because it's been such a commitment I
got one
but we need the rights from Warner
Brothers if anyone knows anyone there
imagine
an entire movie that's set on a computer
but not just any computer
the bat computer
like just think about it man like you're
like you're watching Batman he's like
he's getting hacked by The Riddler and
blah blah like yeah maybe one day I mean
I I put nobody who works on a movie like
this comes out being like yeah let's do
it again you know like it's so much work
that I think there's a hibernation
required from all of us so before we
start being like yeah another screen
Thriller let's let's go do it but it's
just so these guys were up till 3am last
night fixing finding like finishing the
movie you know and it's like it's a very
very intense process but one day I'm
sure because the internet is always
changing and the internet's a very big
place like there'll be more stories to
tell in like four years when we've all
when they've all slept all the hours
seriously paid off I find this to be one
of the most exciting emerging
storytelling formats out there right now
so I can't wait to see more in this
particular format
anybody out there have questions
firsthand that shot up
I'll repeat that question quickly just
so we get it for the camera and your
question gets heard but we're talking
about what's difficult with with green
screen and if you get uh camera operator
credit because of how much of that you
do in this film
um thank you for your question I think
this was the most challenging thing that
I have ever done as an actress
um and I have done green screen before
and it is hard because you're
essentially doing the same thing you are
having to imagine the unimaginable
sometimes but I think there is such a
physicality that you have with green
screen most times it's usually stunts
and you're able to move around we were
in like a real confined space because we
are having to fit in a screen so I think
um you know acting with with the
computer was a little bit more
challenging and I don't know if I got a
DP credit maybe I should just kidding
all right right there uh first first
part is did I see a picture of Michael
Tucker from lessons from the screenplay
and if that's the case like I I'm
wondering like how how the whole online
uh like YouTube movie in uh this course
has like informed U.S filmmaker like
like in the forms of movie analysis and
movie essays like how does that uh
educate you as filmmaker absolutely yeah
I love that question
um and great eye uh they actually uh
came to an early cut of the movie they
gave us notes uh on uh on the previous
um so we love them and and they did a
great lessons from the screenplay on
searching right yeah
um we all consume that stuff TV Tropes
and and
um and video essays on film like that we
love that stuff
um so it was a fun opportunity to give
those things a shout out anything you
guys want to add severe Nation no that
was it
well I think we're going to be able to
get to a lot so right there in the black
shirt in the middle first hey guys um
first off great great job everyone uh
you guys did great work um this is
mainly for Seb
um what were some stuff that you learned
from your time as producer on like other
projects that you carried over into
missing
oh man thank you that's a great question
um so you know I've I've been fortunate
to produce a bunch of other movies
outside of you know searching and
missing I was a producer on Judas and
black Messiah I was producer on Creed 3
which is coming out March 3rd but
obviously watch this movie first
um this comes out January 20th uh and um
you know I've been lucky enough to start
working on like even really bigger
projects like some Marvel stuff I'm
working on it worked on Space Jam and I
have honestly the the thing that I've
learned the most is somewhat of the
validation and like tying it back to the
previous question that it doesn't matter
how big the budget gets or how plentiful
the resources get the most important
resource you're ever going to have is
the right team
and if that team is committed to the
same vision and collaborating with each
other and again like aiming for trying
to tell a cool story that's interesting
and all the beautiful words that storm
listed genuinely I mean this truly
candidly that is what matters so to me I
brought a lot of gratitude to this team
on this film thank you
all right I'm going across this way in
back there in the gray shirt classes
right hi uh big fan of everybody here
um my question is mainly to the writers
and the directors uh so the directors
first when you were editing searching
was there anything creatively that you
thought oh if I was detecting this I
would do this differently that you got
to do in this film
oh man I wish I could remember some of
that
I think we had always wanted to do that
Edgar Wright sort of like flashy editing
and we just couldn't find a place for it
first of all John chose kind of like
this more cumbersome Mouse it's a very
different style of Animation but uh I
think that's one thing that we were
really excited about and when we got the
treatment we're like yes it's a young
protagonists
um that we were like yeah we're gonna
get some Edgar Wright style sort of
stuff in there so that was one one thing
I was a ruthless critic as an editor and
then trying directing him by myself
a humbling experience I was like Anish
how do can't you just make them do a
good take it turns out it's harder than
that
I love the let's go missing the title
and comes out that was amazing yeah
we did use some After Effects ourselves
all right let's go right below their red
and gray shirt I don't know if I could
see colors anymore that's great it's
great uh the movies um I love searching
love run run love missing
um and really the twist is what kind of
keeps me coming back I'm always trying
to figure it out I never figure it out
and so my question was I I like when you
when the twist is happening you like
give us time to figure out what it is by
like zooming in slowly like how do you
decide how much time to give because you
obviously want you don't want to
undermine us and think that we take we
need too long to do it but you also want
to make sure you give us enough time to
figure it out because there's a lot of
things going on especially in this one
that's a great question Natalie you want
to talk about our testing process yeah I
was going to say a big a big part of our
process as a team is getting feedback so
we'll work on the project for a bit and
then we'll put it in front of an
audience because that's really the only
way to feel it out because we'll sit in
the room and like beat each other up
like take two frames off no it's too
long it's too short it gets really
heated in there but until we put it in
front of an audience you can't tell and
you can usually feel it in the room if
it's too short or too long so we rely on
you guys so like there's a thing that
Nat does where she goes like who saw
that moment like raise your hands or
like who didn't see that moment and
we're always trying to find that like
right calibration of like just enough
people who saw it and then a couple of
people who didn't and that's when you
kind of know for example when we asked
when he asked about the title srch that
was a perfect example yeah no hands no
hands you guys don't trust that movie
yeah could still be a hashtag that's
China I don't know
um I think we could take oh God there's
so many questions let's do two more
well this is so overwhelming I just
looked you right in the eye I have to
here wait I'm gonna give you my
microphone
thank you uh all of you it was a great
film and I also saw searching it was
great
um my question is for storm it's uh two
acting questions uh the first was uh
what did you and Nia long do to develop
like the mother-daughter Bond you know
the strong bond between each other and
portray that on the screen I think I
mean it was amazing getting to work with
Miss Nia
um and even though we didn't get to
share a lot of scenes together in the
film um the time that we did get to spin
together
um it was just us and we had a lot of
time to spend together and I think it
it's just really about creating a
rapport and a bond as much as possible
um and I I think it it helps when you
work with like-minded nice people
um and this whole team I feel like felt
comfortable around each other it became
like a little family so it wasn't hard
to create that Rapport on and off camera
with Miss Nia so I'm grateful for that
we're going to take one more question
and then go to the giveaway
I'm going right hi that was a great
movie I just want to say that first
um you guys use a variety of apps like
messenger Facebook Instagram I was
wondering if you guys ever considered
using other apps but didn't make it into
the movie
like be real or Twitter like those
okay we threw out be real recently but I
think we're barely in there yeah it's
honor it's on our home screen one of the
frustrating things about making a movie
like this is it's so slow and the
internet and Technology changes rapidly
out from under you so you're constantly
kind of change chasing things but uh
just to give you one example Zoom
doesn't really make an appearance and
that's that's
um that was around when we were writing
and what we found was we had a whole
scene if you remember on Zoom where
June's kind of hanging out with her
friends and what we found was when when
we came up on this it was early on in
the movie it almost gave the movie it
made it feel just by association that it
was a pandemic movie
um in some ways just because we're
associated with that and um it cheapened
the movie in some ways and and kind of
um so that that's one example of
something that we killed actually
um anything else that comes to mind
be real you have to kind of pick a date
in the future that this movie takes
place in you know so if we started
working on hypothetically finding you
know right now we'd have to be like okay
it's gonna take place in August of 2025
and then you designed the film and then
on August of 2025 you kind of just like
look at the internet and you're like oh
[ __ ] okay what's new what did we not
expect be real was one of those things
that just came too late but technically
it would have been we did throw be real
up in on her phone oh thank God we have
to be real yeah yeah so we got it in
there we got in there and we'll make
sure for the next one to go ahead and
write in the societal collapse in
advance
they're basically like making a period
movie even though it's very modern
because like Advanced literally yeah in
advance because everything just goes out
of date while we're working on it I just
remember the like I remember there was a
day I walked into the Ed office and
everyone was devastated it was like the
worst thing had ever happened I was like
oh my God like did we delete the movie
like what happened and the answer was
that like iOS had updated its software
and they have to go and redesign all the
texts and all this stuff and it was it
was pretty because if like apple if
FaceTime changes and for some reason the
way it closes is on a different side of
the screen or it's showing something
else like these guys have designed the
entire movie so that the actors are
looking and behaving in a certain way if
Apple goes up and just changes something
on us it's very it's a painful yeah the
whole aspect ratio of FaceTime changed
and we'd already shot it in an aspect
ratio so it was vertical now it's
horizontal and now we have lights in the
frame we're like oh Photoshop out the
lights remember you guys you guys were
like indignant you're like what were
they thinking Apple what is this right
this is actually just certainly doesn't
look good good right
We complain about things changing but
then we get used to it in a Flash so if
you don't reflect that I can understand
we have three posters sign posters to
give away I have trivia questions here I
am relying on you all to tell me
whoever's hand shoots up first with an
answer they're not very difficult now I
wish they work a lot of you seem to know
what you're talking about
all right the first question who knows
the names of the two stars of the movie
run
and Sarah Paulson let's go
well done so you get stay there right
now make sure you come find me over here
after we're done and I'll get you a
poster dude that was awesome one poster
well done oh yeah all right in the movie
searching there's a reference to another
screen Thriller another screen Life
movie what movie is that
I love this movie
yes it's unfriended unfriended yes nice
we got two all right there's one more
left
name another really cool movie that
you'll be able to see storm in this year
moving who saw hand I saw lots of hands
yeah like right at the top right there
right but the hand went away
say it
no show it's a big movie really big
movie
you already won oh
hey
did you look it up
quick Google you win you guys thank you
all so much for being here
thank you